powerful new photo teaches us that women
aren't the only ones who get period this
was on Huffington Post they wanted us to
know that men are capable of getting
periods to know oh god said science also
questioned by the way what this paper
was a highly suspicious funding source
of the story when you look see they're
just trying to open up their markets or
just through their ad capilla men or men
could get periods too this is what
they're pushing here at hopping in coast
it's so confusing we were quick to judge
but we're all second-guessing ourselves
because it's male 2 it's female to male
transgender can get their periods but
then we don't necessarily know what
their stance is on male to female
transgender this person actually claimed
to be queer so that sort of throws a
wrench in the works ok we were confused
ourselves can men men straight to to
clear this up we have someone following
this beat our on the ground feet on the
field fact-checking reporter let's go on
the field fact-checking reporter can you
tell us fallen out story is it true that
men can men straight too
[Music]
it almost clears up nothing it almost
just though it's a roll that's not
really useful here but he's on retainer
so before we get to the obvious
violation of logic Instagram this is
where we found it they posted this
picture up there now Instagram you
should note recently removed a picture
of not gay Jerrod in a towel as a
violation of its serving up they
actually no we actually removed that
look a man sitting on a park bench men
string with bloody pants we're a little
fuzzy on the rule haha so again this
comes in a ton heels of Lauren southern
losing her patreon that the double
standards you don't just want to say but
look there's a double standard but it
really matters at this point because it
is so clear that there's there's a
selective censorship of speech and in
encouraging to self-censor because now
that they just said men get periods to
guess what if you say will actually know
now hate speech yeah hate speech that
all them and you keep widening that
umbrella is hate speech strike one two
and three this is removing the
empowerment of women right so think
about this for a second not too long ago
the BuzzFeed women they were painting
with their menstruation why they said
we're going to fight back against period
shaming we think that periods are a
beautiful thing no not a huge fan of
that I don't think of it necessarily
beautiful things but this was to empower
women that we can give life and this is
a natural process of us and what our
organs are required to do in order to
give life okay I can kind of understand
the logic there you're proud your life
givers but now we're just saying well
men can do it too
so we're stripping women of if and by
the way here's something else too in
trying to validate this female to male
transgender this is why the left is just
cannibalizing itself in trying to
validate the female to male transgender
it's saying men can men straight too
this man has a vagina because basically
his sexual organs are still a woman so
in trying to validate him saying you are
just as you are just as much a man as
anyone else so we're going to say men
can men straight - what about the male
to female transgender he was hoping to
be validated through the Beauty guess
what
she can't men straight a lot of people
don't realize this genital surgery does
not give ovaries a uterus or cervix
medical science is far from being able
to transplant those female reproductive
organs for anyone trans or not so when
trying to validate the female to male
trans
you've now insulted the male to female
trans because you're single men can men
straight a lot of male - Fiats so the
only person who can't men straight
is the male to female this is who wants
to be a woman giving it I can't have I
can't have the bloody whose picture on
Instagram the left is trying you're not
trying to empower women yes this is the
way they begin them firearms by the
droves
yes they be giving them firearms by the
droves teaching them how to defend
everything and praising the things that
women do that men cannot do right if
they really want to do empower women and
this is all one issue I think this is
why people are going back and revisiting
the same-sex marriage issue because the
whole concept of that was there's
nothing that a mother can provide that
two fathers can't or vice versa it
basically said men and women are the
exact same and that's why you're seeing
this whole G it's a nuclear arms of who
can get the silliest when it comes to
gender right 57 genders whatever the
hell it is so we're not empowering women
by saying hey you know what
look let's empower women you are mothers
you give life hey let's empower women
look you have an ability for compassion
that men generally don't have let's
empower women women you are sensitive
you are nurturers women you are able to
take care of children in a way that men
can't women you are able to
problem-solve in a way that men can't
now they can solve problems in ways that
you can't but there are so many ways
that you're unique as a woman let's
undergo debt and then instead they say
women can be badass to female action
stars and you try and empower them to do
something that they will invariably be
worse at than a man take Charlize their
own take anyone from Jack Reacher to all
these people tell them how they do their
own sons that they're going to get the
shot out of them just like you take a
man have him try to give birth just what
he did pretty so it's like trying to
empower LeBron James by encouraging him
to be a jockey you can do it if you you
just did no listen let it and Curt on
empower him as LeBron James
look the forefoot to anemic guy be the
junkie he's just hanging on for the ride
by the way no it was to give me one
jockey in the comment section RS hard
all true I'm sure it's hard to pass the
butter tray I get your whole life is
self-denial I get it's not easy the left
is reached so far with this and it is
all tied together that's why you know
we'll talk about Bernie Sanders later
the economic authoritarianism the
same-sex marriage issue the feminism and
now the gender bender they're all one on
the same because it's
pression Olympics as oh and Benjamin is
referred to it so I mean justjust in the
most egregious offenses offensive how
can the left logically support now the
segregation of blacks here they are on
Vox talking about it though it's a good
thing Caitlyn Jenner wins Woman of the
Year despite not being a woman for even
a year gays for Islam you make sense of
this one
it's not new in us pointing out double
standards what I'm pointing out is that
the men can have periods to is just
another step it's going to get they if
three years ago you could say this to
the biggest Obama supporter they would
come on listen yeah oh so your sinks the
would next thing you're going to compare
us to you're going to say we're going to
try to normalize pedophilia salon get
three articles under normalize
pedophilia yeah that you're going to say
that uh I don't know we're enough
pictures of trans people with periods in
their pants and Instagram is that what
you're afraid of
yes they go so far so quickly and logic
is not there's no perimeter at all of
logic to the left this is what's crazy
I'm not why are you general I think I am
generalizing about leftism this is a
part of progressivism progressivism
leftism logic is not a component will
talk about this with Jordan Peterson it
is only compassion and compassion the
absence of truth becomes misguided and
that's how you end up with this guy
nominated for an Emmy sexuality spectrum
everyone that's on it even you might
like it
if you sit top on it oh I don't like
there and I'm not sitting up on it if
you like this clip it's taken from the
fold Daily Show available exclusively
allotted with credit calm slash mug club
that's for mug club members because we
can't be dependent here in the Google
YouTube overlords subscribe there we
have a Daily Show full hour every day if
you don't well
there's no saving you